foreign
[Music]
CBS deals and this morning we have
products that you might find make your
day a bit brighter and a little bit
easier and all exclusively low prices to
start shopping now scan the QR code on
your screen or visit
cbsdeals.com Jessica Tice Deputy editor
of the Good Housekeeping Institute joins
us now with more and good morning good
morning Michelle yes definitely head to
cbsdeals.com now these are going to go
quick what do we have here this isn't a
an electric blanket it's an electric
heating pad yes this is the calming Heat
this is a weighted heating pad you have
to feel it it is so soft it's amazing
and has a really nice soothing vibration
so if you have any pain or if you just
want to be super cozy at home it's
amazing so heated here yes heated and
you can feel it has this nice Teddy
fabric so cozy but you also feel these
clay beads inside oh yeah our lab
experts at the Good Housekeeping
Institute confirmed that these help keep
the heat evenly distributed perfect just
like that you're rocking it isn't it so
comfortable on your on your back yes and
you see how long the cord is too so you
don't have to worry about moving it
around has nine adjustable settings and
if you fall asleep underneath it like I
did and everybody in my family did Auto
two hour shut off I love it yeah I love
it 30 off 42 dollars today 42 bucks okay
what's next okay so getting stuck on the
side of the road is a worse nightmare
right for a lot of us we did that on the
story that we're doing today yeah see a
reality for a lot of us okay so this is
the track Grabber this is a tire
traction block and it's designed to get
you out of snow sand mud year round all
by yourself that's ingenious yeah so it
straps on really easily I was actually
able to do it myself in under a minute
which with these nails if anyone else
can do it faster I'm sure they can you
didn't break a nail I didn't break a
nail it was super easy I was really
impressed how much is this this is 25
option you can get it for 45 must have
for anybody with a car the smell is
snuggy it's hard to think of a product
more iconic right I know this is so
popular can you believe it I do not have
it I know well okay so you are one of
the rare few because over 30 million of
these have been sold and today is your
day because at cbsdeals.com buy one get
one so I want to get one look around buy
one get one free oh it's this way yes
flip it around the other way and you'll
see the beauty of the Snuggie which is
those sleeves that keep everything in
place so it's not going to slip it's the
perfect weight it's not going to fall
off of you so I've been this is how I've
been looking all week this is my look of
the week because it's just perfect and
one size fits most which we love with a
belt I think it will I think it's kind
of a mood is that is that going to be
the look for the next segment I think
maybe so again buy one get one free
today on the Snuggie Beauty okay so this
is beauty stat this is a top selling
brand for cbsdeals.com all the time so
I'm really excited to be able to
highlight this black owned beauty brand
during Black History Month oh love it
and so this is you have your C your
vitamin C your moisturizer your eye
perfector and what is this oh this is
their hero product this is the universal
sea skin perfector and this is actually
what Haley Bieber called her Holy Grail
skincare product really yes and I can
totally see why after using it this week
it is so smooth you have to try some on
okay it is so smooth it is so velvety
you'll see how it just goes on your hand
and melts right in I'm totally addicted
to it it has 20 vitamin C which is a
really high concentration and our Beauty
lab experts at The Institute confirm
that it's the most pure and absorbable
so it's a moisturizer with vitamin C in
it it's a Serum with vitamins but it
feels like a moisturizer because it's so
hydrating right yeah it really is it's
such a nice feeling so 50 off today so
you can get the universal sea skin
perfector starting at 43 dollars but
everything here is 50 off so
cbsdeals.com for whatever you might need
can you get it all together if you want
okay yep thank you Jessica thank you
well of course we partner with all these
companies to get these deals so to buy
anything you saw today just scan that QR
code on your screen or head over to
cbsdeals.com